[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans ce nouveau débat
diffusé sur tv 78 radio sensations
un débat dans le cadre du second tour
des élections municipales 2020 avec les
trois candidats des clayes-sous-bois ce
second tour a été reporté au dimanche 28
juin en raison de l'épidémie liée aux
cours aux navires us et comme vous le
voyez les candidats ne sont pas en
plateau avec moi mais à distance du à
cette crise sanitaire
ils ne sont plus que trois candidats à
vouloir devenir mère des
clayes-sous-bois anne-claire frémont
tête de liste les clayes-sous-bois c'est
vous bonsoir bonsoir également nicolas
hué tête de liste un autre projet pour
les clayes-sous-bois bonsoir et enfin
philippe guiguen tête de liste les clés
avec vous 2020 vont soir pourquoi et
sachez que lors de ce débat votants de
paroles seront chronométrés ils
s'afficheront lors de l'émission et
selon l'ordre des listes fournies par la
préfecture des yvelines
c'est vous philippe blidéenne qui allait
commencer mais avant de débuter ce débat
le rappel des gens des enjeux et les
résultats aux clayes-sous-bois regarder
depuis le premier tour des élections
municipales beaucoup d'événements
inattendus se sont produits cette
pandémie mondiale mais aussi aux
clayes-sous-bois le retrait de la
candidate stéphanie jamin tête de liste
énergie positive c'est donc une
triangulaire pour ce second tour avec
une seule liste de gauche celle de
nicolas eu
il sera opposé à philipp digue est née
anne claire frémont sur la liste de
cette dernière figure la maire sortante
véronique côté millard qui a pourtant
préféré soutenir son premier adjoint
philippe dit guen il est arrivé en
première position avec 31 68 % des voix
lors du premier tour des élections
municipales le taux d'abstention était
de +2 59%
ces trois candidats s'affrontent pour
devenir mère des clayes-sous-bois
commune de 17 1842 habitants on l'a vu
pendant cette crise sanitaire la
nécessité des médecins de ville
mais aux clayes-sous-bois on note une
forte diminution du nombre de praticiens
et les départs en retraite non remplacés
la création d'une maison de santé
pluridisciplinaire est souhaitée pour
pallier cette pénurie
médecin cette crise sanitaire touche
également le commerce local
les candidats souhaitent soutenir les
producteurs locaux et redynamiser le
commerce de proximité
un problème se pose le stationnement
payant dans le centre ville ou encore
près du centre socioculturel philippe
noiret il est la cause de perte de
fréquentation des commerces de la ville
autres enjeux les objectifs de logements
sociaux à atteindre ils sont de 24,6
pour cent que les sous bois pour un
objectif fixé par la loi de 25% d'ici
2025 les 0,4 pour cent représente une
cinquantaine de logements dans la ville
des futurs logements vont sortir de
terre en 2021
enfin la sécurité la vidéosurveillance
la culture ou encore l'environnement
sont des enjeux importants pour les
clayes-sous-bois philippe guillen lors
du premier tour des élections
municipales vous êtes arrivé premier
avec 31,68 % des voix comment auriez
vous géré cette crise sanitaire en tant
que maire cette crise sanitaire
en tant que mère je l'aurais j'irai en
étant au maximum de la proximité des
habitants tout en respectant bien
entendu le règles qui nous était imposé
j'aurais essayé comme l'a fait madame le
maire d'aller apporter son secours avec
des distributions menace que nous avons
pu obtenir de la part de la région au
sein à destination de l'ensemble du
personnel soignant
j'aurais essayé d'organiser le commerce
local comme cela a pu se faire en partie
et j'aurais essayé d'assumer un minimum
de services au service de la de la
population notamment en les informant
sur tout ce qui était possible et non
possible avec la frémont tête de liste
les clayes-sous-bois c'est vous comment
abordez-vous en éventuel mandat dans ces
conditions une difficulté supplémentaire
nous allons dire parce que nous ne
sommes pas sortis de cette crise
ça va durer encore plusieurs mois il va
falloir s'adapter et budgétairement et
il ya beaucoup de
mais je pense que cette crise sanitaire
m'a fait réfléchir par rapport aux noms
que nous avons eu sur notre ville est
entre autres pour moi ce qu'il aurait
été était important d'avoir eu que nous
n'avons pas c'est un plan communal de
sauvegarde qui justement permet
d'anticiper ces crises d'anticiper des
moyens de communication avec avec la
population et je pense que c'est ce qui
nous a manqué au début
comment continuer à communiquer avec
tout le monde et surtout avec les
personnes isolées et les personnes qui
avaient besoin d'une réponse très rapide
et entre autres qui avaient besoin de
quelqu'un pour aller leur faire les
courses donc c'était vital et on s'est
rendu compte que nous avons été très
long à mettre ces choses en place après
ça a été fait correctement et ce plan
communal de sauvegarde aura eu tout son
intérêt mais nous aurions gagné du temps
le taux d'abstention au premier tour aux
clayes-sous-bois était de 59,3 % comment
appréhendez-vous le second tour nicolas
hulot l'appréhendent de la meilleure
manière possible
aujourd'hui mme que la crise que nous
connaissons de crise sanitaire et la
pandémique qui j'espère reflux le plus
possible en ce moment nous l'abordons
avec avec conviction toujours et puis
avec optimisme mais évidemment avec
beaucoup de précautions à respecter par
rapport à ce que nous avons connu je re
jouer madame frémont sur le manque
d'anticipation
nous avons en face j'ai en face de moi
de deux maires adjoints sortants jeu
j'approuve le fait qu'il n'y a pas eu
une anticipation assez importante de de
la crise est en tout cas l'organisation
d'un plan local de santé et du handicap
comme nous le réclamions depuis des
années qui nous auraient permis je pense
de d'anticiper le mieux possible cette
crise est en tout cas je tiens à saluer
mois les lots formidable élan de
solidarité qui s'est porté
aux clayes-sous-bois de la part de
nombreux chrétiens et de nombreux
commerçants qui dès les premières
semaines les premiers jours de
confinement se sont portés volontaires
pour apporter leur aide et leur soutien
aux chrétiens et je pense que c'est une
grande leçon à retenir au moins de sept
de ses deux mois oublie t
pendant cette crise sanitaire nous avons
pu constater également la nécessité des
médecins de ville mais aux
clayes-sous-bois on note une forte
diminution du nombre de médecins et les
départs en retraite sont non remplacés
parmi elles les propositions de chacun
la création d'une maison de santé
pluridisciplinaire
comment faciliter l'arrivée de nouveaux
médecins et les attirer aux
clayes-sous-bois anne klein frémont ça
va être un des enjeux du mandat déjà là
déjà la première chose pour nous ça va
être de créer un conseil un conseil de
santé parce que si nous voulons trouver
la meilleure solution pour attirer moi
j'irai des professionnels de santé et
des paramédicaux parce qu'aujourd'hui ce
ne sont pas les médecins qui manque le
plus dans les années à venir oui parce
qu'on a des départs en retraite mais ce
sont surtout les paramédicaux entre
autres les je pense au kinésithérapeute
nous n'en avons plus qu'un sur la ville
dont crée un conseil de santé avec des
représentants de tout de tout l'est de
toutes les professions des habitants des
élus afin de voir exactement les
manquements sur la ville et qu'est-ce
qu'il faut mettre en place et comment on
se rend compte que les médecins d'hier
ne sont plus les médecins d'aujourd'hui
ils ne veulent plus être corvéables à
merci faire des journées de 20 heures et
il faut s'adapter à tout ça donc là la
réponse et la maison pluridisciplinaire
de santé n'est pas forcément le
recrutement de médecins parce que ça
coûte cher on à 80000 euros par an je
pense qu'on n'a pas les moyens et je
pense que c'est pas la solution mais
c'est leur donner des locaux et la
possibilité de fonctionner avec les ans
des horaires qui leur conviennent
aujourd'hui philippe guiguen vous êtes
élu e aux clayes-sous-bois depuis 2001
vous souhaitez renforcer l'offre de
service médical en partenaire
avec les services de 50 ans ni vis du
département mais aussi des
professionnels médicaux et paramédicaux
comment allez-vous mettre en place ce
comité local des professionnels de santé
alors déjà une remarque peu par rapport
à ce que l'a dit madame frais non je
partage sa vision qu'il faut à la fois
des médecins des paramédicaux et
également des spécialistes mais où ne
l'a rejoint passé sur le coup des
éventuels médecins qui sont embauchés au
niveau de la commune parce que
effectivement un médecin coûte entre 50
et 60 des 60000 euros
mais nous avons le remboursement quasi
équivalent de la part de la sécurité
sociale donc personnellement moi je
n'excluerais pas là l'embauchent deux
médecins au niveau de la commune ensuite
au niveau de l'agglomération de la
région et du département
il faut savoir que nous avons des aides
très très substantiel puisque au niveau
de la région nous pouvons avoir jusqu'à
quatre cent cinquante mille euros
dead pour ce projet si ce projet est
validé par la rs au niveau du
département nous pouvons avoir également
30000 euros
dead pour ce mail ce même type de projet
et enfin nous pouvons faciliter grâce à
des bourses que l'on peut donner à des
étudiants en médecine de l'université de
saint quentin avec des supports de la
part du département
nicolas hulot vous souhaitez créer un
conseil de santé et du handicap
tout à fait nous avons vu à travers ces
mois compliqués que nous avons vécu
qu'il y avait donc un gros manque
en terme de deux liens avec le personnel
soignant sur la commune et il nous
paraît aujourd'hui important comme je le
réclamait depuis quelques années
d'installer un conseil local de la santé
du handicap
regroupant l'ensemble des personnels
soignants de la commune et qui
permettrait justement de travailler au
maillage des besoins sur la commune
et qui nous permettrait aussi
d'accompagner le plus possible les
personnes en fragilité en vulnérabilités
sur la maison de santé et la maison
pluridisciplinaire de santé
moi je constate une chose c'est que
c'est un petit peu les l'occasion les
occasions manquées
cette maison pluridisciplinaire de santé
il ya quelques années le département a
fait un appel à projets nous aurions pu
y contribuer et nous aurions pu
bénéficier d'une aide d'un million 4 de
subvention pour la réalisation et la
construction de deux sets les emplois et
disciplinaire de santé sur le
fonctionnement tant que tel d'un cp m
il ya quelques années a débloqué des
fonds à hauteur de 47 millions d'euros
pour l'ensemble des sept cent trente
cinq maisons de santé qui se sont
construits ces trois dernières années
nous aurions pu bénéficier année après
année d'une aide de d'à peu près 65
mille euros sur notre cette maison de
santé qui aurait permis de mutualiser de
faire fonctionner déjà cette maison de
santé depuis quelques quelques années
nous le voyons il ya des maisons de
santé qui sont en place et qui existe
depuis un an maintenant notamment sur
triel sur seine ou autre quatorze
médecins pluridisciplinaires sont au
sein de cet établissement et des
médecins recrutés via l'université de
saint quentin en yvelines
nous sommes dans saint quentin en
yvelines je pense qu'il est important
aujourd'hui d'être proactif sur cette
question là sur ce domaine avec la fré
mon fils ils viennent vous faites partie
de l'ancienne majorité une réaction sur
cette maison de santé pluridisciplinaire
président philipp degen
cette maison sera atteint disciplinaire
c'est un véritable enjeu de la de la
part de la de la mandature nous devront
effectivement la réaliser nous avons
différents endroits où nous pouvons la
positionner nous devrons nous appuyer
sur un comité comme ça a été expliquée
local des professionnels de santé et
avec tous les supports dont je bénéficie
au niveau du département et ainsi par
équivalent c'est ce qui a été réalisé
sur des villes comme montigny le
bretonneux où ce qui est en cours au
niveau 2
de voisins-le-bretonneux à l'heure
actuelle je suis tout à fait confiant
sur la réalisation de cette maison de
santé à très moyen clem madame frémont
moi je dirais qu'aujourd'hui la question
n'est pas est ce qu'on aurait pu mieux
faire
on est en retard il fallait faire avant
c'est un des gros enjeux de notre mandat
comme disait monsieur guy yens bien
évidemment c'est un dossier qu'il faudra
travailler mais que n'importe quelle
personne qui va être élu en tant que mr
travaillera avec saint quentin en
yvelines avec le département avec la
région avec la rs en premier parce qu'en
effet c'est la rs qui donne les
autorisations
donc ça c'est une évidence par contre là
où c'est un enjeu ça va être un enjeu
pour le maire qui va être élu ces deux
d'essayer de mettre en place la maison
pluridisciplinaire qui correspond aux
clés siens et aux clés ciel est de faire
venir une mutuelle municipal oui tout à
fait c'est dans notre programme
alors la mutuelle municipal
contrairement à peut-être ce qu'ont dit
certains outils c'est pas de mettre des
personnes en contact avec avec certaines
mutuelles parce que je pense qu'ils sont
capables de le faire eux mêmes ces deux
dalles et d'aller taper à la porte des
mutuelles et ça a du sens d'ailleurs de
ne pas le faire que à échelle de ville
ça a du sens de le faire avec les
communes limitrophes villepreux plaisir
voire même les communes de saint quentin
en yvelines et d'aller voir les
migraines et les mutuelles edgar voilà
nous avons tant de clients potentiels
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous proposer
pour comme contrat ce qui permet d'avoir
des contrats à très bas prix avec une
bonne assurance et ce qui peut permettre
à tout le monde d'avoir une mutuelle et
après pour les plus fragiles
il ya également le ccas qui rentrera en
ligne de compte philippe guiguen vous
proposer également une mutuelle
je propose une vision qui est très
proche de celle de madame alain frémont
c'est à dire une négociation globale
pour faire obtenir à l'ensemble d'une
majorité de deux clés siens des tarifs
réduits par contre ceux qui n'auraient
pas la possibilité
de bénéficier de cette mutuelle même à
tarif réduit là où nous pouvons dans le
cadre du ccas venir en aide à ces
personnes
la mutualisation elle l'a sera valable
dans les années à venir
au niveau des mutuelles mais également
au niveau de plein d'autres activités
sur les différentes communes et sur
l'agglomération
on jette un coup d'oeil sur les temps de
parole nicolas hulot vous êtes à trois
minutes
anne-claire frémont quatre minutes 05
effet libre guiguen trois minutes 16 on
passe à une autre thématique le commerce
local avec cette crise sanitaire les
producteurs locaux étaient soutenus et
nicholas hughes vous habitez aux
clayes-sous-bois depuis 47 ans
comment allez-vous redynamiser le
commerce de proximité
juste avant tout je voulais juste
revenir sur la question des mutuelles je
comprends mieux pourquoi madame très bon
et messieurs qui viennent se partagent
madala côté millard puisqu'ils sont
d'accord sur des questions sauveur
habituel sur sur la question du commerce
il est évident aujourd'hui que nous
devons avoir une une lors d'une
intervention très proactive en direction
du commerce de proximité
nous avons vu pendant cette période de
confinement l'intérêt et l'importance
des commerces de proximité et le besoin
qu'il y avait au sein de notre commune
d'avoir un maillage que moi j'ai déjà
parents d'un maillage social le commerce
de proximité pour moi ce n'est pas
uniquement de la vente et du retrait des
aliments ou de produits ou de
fournitures c'est aussi un lien social
ce lien social organisé par les
commerces il est fondamental je constate
malheureusement que la majorité sortante
s'est focalisée uniquement sur les
commerces de périphérie qui ont peu
petit à petit et bien fait péricliter le
commerce de centre-ville le commerce de
proximité
nous en avons des retours aidés témoigne
un jeu régulier depuis quelques années
maintenant nous savons que les commerces
de proximité ont perdu à peu près 20 à
30% de leur chiffre d'affaires et de
fréquentation en centre ville
et moi je m'étonne fortement que dans
une commune comme la nôtre avec un fort
potentiel comme celui ci nous n'ayons
pas un service de l'économie et de
l'emploi
et c'est une des premières mesures que
je mettrai en place d'installer un
service de l'économie et de l'emploi
pour redynamiser le commerce de centre
ville et de proximité
et puis pour travailler aussi aux liens
avec l'ensemble des commerçants qui ont
eu énormément de choses à nous apporter
parce que on peut faire des choses à
deux cerveaux mais à plusieurs cerveaux
on y arrivera bien plus certainement
philippe guen vous souhaitez disposer de
locaux permettant l'installation de
commerces et magasins éphémères
vous pensez que c'est ça la clé pour
redynamiser les clayes-sous-bois avant
de vous répondre précisément sur ce coin
sont soit pas ainsi je pense que au
niveau de commerce de proximité eu la
crise que nous venons passé il ya déjà
deux niveaux d' analyse bien le court
terme où il va falloir aller essayer
d'aider les commerçants qui seraient en
difficulté au niveau de la région et au
niveau du département nous avons voté
des fonds de soutien donc les
commerçants qui vont avoir des
difficultés ça sera de notre
responsabilité de les aider pour obtenir
ces fonds et à plus moyen terme
il faut effectivement redynamiser tout
le commerce local avec d'une part
création d'associations de commerçants
parce que nous ne pouvons pas au niveau
de la municipalité décider tout seul lui
devons le faire en partenariat et de
façon très très forte avec ses
commerçants
ce partenariat ils tous accompagnés avec
eux par qui marche très très bien parce
que il faut pas se priver d'aller
prendre ce qui marche bien dans les
communes avoisinantes avec par exemple
un manager de proximité à plaisir qui
permet justement des décès comme ces
commerçants pour ce qui est des magasins
éphémères cela peut être effectivement
une solution pour voir la viabilité d'un
commerce en centre ville donc c'est une
de nos de nos propositions et d'autres
propositions pour les commerçants cesse
de l'est de les aider au niveau de leurs
de l'information qu'ils peuvent être
amenés à divulguer un ensemble des clés
siens avec par exemple une page
régulière sur notre revue et
sion des pages régulière sur tout ce qui
est numérique il faut que nos
commerçants cinéma et soient connus tout
comme philippe viguet nan claf raymond
vous souhaitez engager un manager de
commerce local et développe également
une application pour faire connaître les
commerçants oui déjà ce que je voudrais
bien c'est que nous sommes une me semble
si je me trompe les seuls à avoir sur
notre liste des commerçants des anciens
commerçants nous avons même là
l'ancienne vice présidente de
l'association des commerçants dont je
pense que nous sommes extrêmement bien
placé pour savoir les premiers matic
pour gérer et de gérer un commerce et
par rapport à ça ce qu'il en découle
c'est que déjà ça doit être un
partenariat est en effet un partenariat
entre l'école et la ville et pour aider
ce partenariat la un manager de commerce
local peut permettre de faire le lien en
effet ça fonctionne très bien sûr
d'autres villes me permettre de contenir
voire les besoins les besoins gérer les
animations donc oui c'est important mais
ça ne fera pas tout il faut en effet rim
analyser mais des animations en place
amener tout le monde à revers son
commerce local on pensait qu en effet
cette pandémie que nous traversons à les
faire revenir un petit peu les habitants
vers leur commerce local ils sont
revenus mais malheureusement beaucoup en
sont repartis donc il va falloir que
l'on trouve les solutions et ce sera
encore un des enjeux de ce mandat et
prochainement un centre commercial à
plaisir est-ce que c'est pas une
concurrence directe à à ce commerce
local pour pour pour moi oui enfin c'est
une nouvelle fois ce que je disais tout
à l'heure c'est le commerce de
périphérie on s'est focalisé dessus
enfin les élus en classe la majorité en
place s'est focalisée dessus au
détriment du commerce de centre ville
nous savons aujourd'hui nous avons dans
notre dans notre projet une démarche qui
tendrait à développer la proximité et la
convivialité
on sait pertinemment que si nous voulons
faire en sorte que le commerce local et
le commerce de proximité se développe il
faut y apporter la convivialité
ça peut se faire évidemment par les
associations commerçants pour cela il
faut les soutenir il faut les aider mais
ça peut se faire aussi par des commerces
qui pourraient être eux mêmes sources de
convivialité est source de d'animation
et c'est un enjeu global sur l'ensemble
du centre ville et même des petits
quartiers du quartier nord ou du
quartier ouest qu'il faut prendre en
compte pour justement mettre en place
cette convivialité qui fera revenir les
chrétiens dans nos commerces
madame frémont a tout à fait raison les
les chrétiens se sont habitués pendant
quelques semaines à fréquenter les
commerces de proximité
malheureusement depuis lors je dis
malheureusement tant mieux parce que
nous sommes des confiné mais en même
temps les personnes
les questions ont retrouvé leurs
habitudes et moi je souhaite et
j'aimerais fortement que nous puissions
continuer à valider la démarche que nous
avions eu tous collectivement en en
étant au plus près de nos commerces de
proximité qui sont la source de vie et
de convivialité de notre ville on jette
un coup d'oeil sur vos temps de parole
de nicolas hulot vous avez déjà à six
minutes 39 avec l'affrètement cinq
minutes 19 et philippe guiguen quatre
minutes 50 de l aele du marché c'est un
des points phares de la ville eux
philippe dit guen vous souhaitez tester
l'ouverture de la halle du marché et
certains jours de la semaine pour l art
in l'artisanat d'art je souhaite
utiliser cette cette halle de marché qui
est un investissement quand même lourd
au niveau de la commune et qui est un
investissement sûr sur le long terme
d'ailleurs c'est aussi un investissement
qui va permettre de redynamiser le le
l'ensemble du commerce local
et effectivement nous envisageons de
l'utiliser puisque le marché n'a lieu
que deux demi journées par semaine
d'utiliser cette sûrs pour un certain
nombre de
deux possibilités ça sera ça ne serait
pas réduit à martin à l'artisanat d'art
mais au préalable il faudra que nous
voyons cela avec le gestionnaire du
marché et les commerçants nous irons
petit à petit avec la frime une réaction
alors pour moi c'est pas la priorité ça
déjà la priorité ça va être que notre
marché arrive enfin à ouvrir ça va être
déjà de redynamiser notre marché
ça va bien de faire en sorte qu'on ait
de nouveaux commerçants de privilégier
le local demandé de donner envie aux
clés siens et ovila côté de revenir par
le biais d'animations et une fois qu'on
aura redynamiser ce marché donc on sera
arrivé à faire venir les commerçants qui
sont attendus aujourd'hui
ce sera dans un deuxième gain en effet
d'autres questions se posent et que
pouvons nous faire au plus mais ce n'est
absolument pas la priorité pour le
moment parce que voilà notre marché
d'abord à redynamiser et pour terminer
aussi je voudrais répondre à monsieur
qui disait commerce de périphérie ont
priviligié pas des commerces de
périphérie on n'a pas le choix
ce sont des terrains privés les
investisseurs les achètent ils
s'installent et à partir du moment où
ils répondent au pmu ont ils sont
obligés de s'implanter je pense que
c'est pas de dire commerce de périphérie
tout le monde peut exister c'est nous de
dire comment pouvons-nous faire pour que
nos trois de commerce local vive il faut
donner envie aux chrétiens aqmi ciel et
autres étant des villas à côté à venir
dans ce commerce local il faut se
démarquer
justement du commerce de périphérie et
moi je crois foncièrement ça je si je
peux répondre rapidement parce que vous
êtes à 6 minutes 40 rapidement cette
question là je je me souviens tout de
même qu' il était fortement interdit les
voir web et au moment de l'ouverture de
deux autres cas la réalisation de
certains commerces en périphérie d'y
installer des commerces alimentaires
vous avez réouvert la possibilité
d'ouvrir des commerces alimentaires
nous connaissons donc du côté du
quartier ouest et qui malheureusement
est bien au prix de la clientèle sur les
commerces de proximité de centre ville
ou du quartier ouest en tant que tel
vous déplorez du g10 j'ai disparu
pendant quelques secondes à propos de la
photo du marché ce sera effectivement
l'un des objets d'époque des prochaines
années il faut arriver à faire vivre ce
marché en le différenciant de ce que
l'on peut retrouver dans les grandes
surfaces et sas estime avec du
qualitatif c'est tout à fait possible
avec des circuits courts avec des
produits bio c'est pas pour moi un des
objectifs de ce marché un problème se
pose le stationnement payant dans le
centre ville ou encore près du centre
socioculturel philippe noiret il est la
cause de perte de fréquentation pour les
commerçants anne-claire frémont que
faire concernant les places de
stationnement payant alors il faut
savoir que les places de stationnement
payant ont été mises en place en
concertation avec les commerçants et les
commerçants nous n'avons pas attendu le
stationnement payant pour aller les voir
puisque comme je vous le disais ils ont
été concertées et l'objectif de ce
stationnement payant uniquement là où il
n'y avait des commerces locaux c'est
justement de leur permettre de vivre et
de leur permettre d'avoir des clients
parce que les clients quand ils ne
peuvent pas se garer
ils ne viennent pas il faut aussi dire
que le stationnement n'est pas payant il
ya une heure et demie gratuite et il ya
quand même aussi deux parkings gratuits
qui sont le parking de la gare qui sont
toujours pleins mais le parking de la
poste qui est quand même à moitié
gratuits
voilà il ya une heure et demie gratuit
je le rappelle donc il ya largement
assez pour faire ses courses et encore
une fois ça a été fait à la demande des
commerçants c'est perfectible
je pense qu'il est il y aura certaines
choses adapté et entre autres sept
heures et demie qui une fois qu'on l'a
prise pour un quart d'heure de course
s'est terminée pour la journée ça en
effet c'est à améliorer mais pour moi
c'est la solution parce que sinon si
vous ne mettez pas de stationnement
payant dans ses rues commerçantes et
entre outre l'armory jouer ce sont des
places qui sont prises par les personnes
qui vont à la guerre
et il n'y a pas de place pour se garer
on regarde de temps de parole avec la
frémont vous êtes à 8 minutes nicolas eu
sept minutes 13 et philippe guiguen six
minutes 0-2 justement philippe dégaine
une réaction concernant les problèmes
des stationnements clayes-sous-bois
l'analyste vient de faire madame raymond
je la partage totalement initialement
ces stationnements ont été mis en place
à la demande des commerçants l'objectif
est d'éviter d'avoir des véhicules
ventouses pendant la totalité de la
journée puisqu'il ya la proximité de la
gare donc il est essentiel que les les
clients puissent aller chez les
commerçants 12 stationnement ce
stationnement qui effectivement n'est
pas n'est pas payant puisque nous avons
une heure et demie gratuite
il est par contre est facile de
l'améliorer 7h30 gratuite qui fait que
aujourd'hui une fois que vous êtes
déplacé que vous avez utilisé une ne
serait ce qu un quart d'heure ou 20
minutes
votre heure et demie sur la journée est
consommé nous pouvons très bien faire en
sorte que cette heure et demie soit
fractionnable dans la journée voilà un
exemple concret de ce que nous pouvons
de ce que nous pouvons faire parmi vos
propres vos propositions nicolas eu la
révision du plan de stationnement payant
quel est ce plan oui tout à fait tout
tout à fait parce qu'en fait j'ai
l'impression qu'en fait nous ne
fréquentons pas les mêmes commerçants ou
ne vont pas vu les mêmes commerçants
madame trémouille les messieurs guiguen
parce que aujourd'hui aucun commerçant
ne dit avoir demandé ces stationnements
payants et je veux bien les croire
puisque ce que l'on constate c'est que
le stationnement payant a évidemment
fortement impacté leur activité jusqu'à
en faire perdre une fréquentation et
avoué un chiffre d'affaires assez
conséquent pour certains de 20 à 30%
comme je disais tout à l'heure
moi ce que je ne sais que ce que je vois
avant tout et la différence que je ne
comprends pas c'est pourquoi avoir
enlevé des stationnement en zone bleue
pour le remplacer par des stationnements
pelo nous sommes sur une heure et demie
gratuit à chaque fois sur l'un comme sur
l'autre
pourquoi avoir remplacé les disques qui
existait par du stationnement payant si
ce n'est évidemment pour faire payer les
clés siens à la suite de leur ennemi la
seule le seul moyen pour que ces
stationnements soient régulés et en tout
cas fonctionne de manière cohérente et
c'est d'avoir des moyens humains en face
à partir du moment où nous avons des
moyens humains on fasse pour faire
respecter ces temps de stationnement et
bien les stationnements seront fluides
je constate simplement que le turn-over
au sein des agents de la police
municipale est trop important pour que
nous puissions régler ça aujourd'hui
il va falloir que nous pensions
réellement sur les missions de la police
municipale et des médiateurs de
prévention que nous souhaitons mettre en
place au sein de la commune on regarde
vos temps de parole nicolaï vous êtes en
avance 8 minutes 56 avec l'affrètement 8
minutes et philippe guiguen six minutes
58 vous êtes légèrement en retard une
réaction face aux propos de nicolas eu
la réaction sur ces derniers sur
dernière proposition à proposent chacun
sait qu'il ya important 9 heures sur la
police municipale qu'il ya effectivement
des difficultés pour former ce personnel
qui il ne reste pas suffisamment au
niveau de la commune néanmoins cette
police municipale elle est nécessaire et
c'est pour ça que dans même dans ma
propre aux noix proposition de programme
je souhaite aussi et j'ai commencé déjà
à discuter avec le maire de plaisir sur
une utilisation delà de la police
municipale comme se disait tout à
l'heure il faudra essayer de mutualiser
pour réduire au maximum les coûts et
plus efficace dans beaucoup de domaines
avant de clôturer cette thématique
madame frémont une réaction non vous
avez à présent une carte blanche d'une
minute vous pouvez conclure ou aborder
un thème je demanderai de respecter
vraiment ce temps de parole
on commence par vous
anne-claire frémont ce que je voulais
dire c'est donc du coup dimanche les
clés siens vont avoir le droit le choix
entre une liste de droite est très à
droite une liste de gauche et d'extrême
gauche
ce sont des listes qui sont dans des
logiques politiciennes et qui
appliqueront une politique de droite ou
de gauche mais moi ce que je veux faire
c'est mener une politique pour ma ville
avec son rivage avec une liste citoyenne
remettre au coeur du débat la
citoyenneté le vivre ensemble la
transition écologique la sécurité
garantir la sécurité qui est une grosse
attente des clés sia et lutter contre la
pauvreté et l'isolément et d'isolement
des plus fragiles et je voudrais aussi
m'adresser parce que j'ai vu aussi
pendant toute cette campagne
lorsque nous n'étions pas confiné j'ai
vu pas mal de jeunes et je suis moi même
maman de deux garçons de 21 et 18 ans et
les jeunes ne sont pas concernés ils
nous disent tous notre ville n'est pas
assez dynamique
il n'y a pas ce qu'on veut il n'y a pas
assez d'activités on n'a rien pour aller
boire un verre mais ils vont pas voter
donc moi je vous dis aujourd'hui aller
voter vous pouvez choisir l'avenir c'est
vous c'est beaucoup moins nous donc
aller voter dimanche
choisissez ce que vous voulez pour votre
vie c'est important merci nicolas hulot
vous avez une minute
le 15 mai dernier vous devez placer en
seconde position derrière monsieur diène
et vous nous avez placé en position
d'offrir enfin le changement tant
attendu pour les clés siens après vingt
ans de règne d'une majorité sortante qui
aujourd'hui est divisé en deux comme on
peut le voir soutenu par la maire
sortante pour l'un et accompagné par la
maire sortante pour l'autre c'est assez
incompréhensible
dimanche 28 juin comme d'un très bon
j'appelle tous les chrétiens qui se sont
abstenus lors du premier tour pour des
raisons parfois bien compréhensible à
venir évidemment et bien joué de leur
droit de vote et offrir ce changement
aux chrétiens comme j'appelle tous les
électeurs des l'isiq des deux autres
listes qui se sont présentées aux
seconds qui se sont présentés aux
premiers touristes sont pas présentes ou
second est bien à venir porter ce
changement puisque ces deux listes
souhaitait aussi apporté un nouvel un
nouvel élan et un nouveau souffle pour
notre musique merci
philipp degen vous avez à présent deux
minutes pour conclure la la la période
que nous venons de vivre et ses
conséquences doit nous amener à mon avis
être encore plus solidaire transparent
et unis la liste que je représente c'est
pas du tout une liste politique parce
que je les ai toujours dit pour moi mon
parti c'est ma ville et j'estime que
ceux ci nous pouvons aller vite il nous
devons être ensemble pour pouvoir aller
loin notre ville a donc besoin dans les
années à venir et encore plus compte
tenu de la crise qui dhien qui vient de
se passer d'une équipe qui va allier à
la fois l'expérience et le
renouvellement notre ville elle a besoin
d'un maire qui sera un bon gestionnaire
je pense qu'aucun des candidats ne peut
ne peut être contre celte cette position
considérant que les ressources qui vont
arriver au niveau des communes
cela part de l'état vont continuer à
subir des réductions très drastiques et
c'est la condition pour moi impérative
pour avoir une politique solidaire parce
que nous ne pouvons pas redistribuer ce
que nous ne possédons pas ce maire il
devrait disponible à 100 % ce qui est
mon cas pour notre ville aujourd'hui et
il sachant qu également je ne briguerai
aucun monde en comment autrement dame
bizarre par ma position à la coopération
ce maire de grey à l'ecoute ça a
toujours été ma position dans ma vie
professionnelle mais je ne vois pas
pourquoi ça changerait
au niveau de notre commune ce maire il
devra avoir une expérience suffisante
je l' ai personnellement et l'équipe qui
m'accompagne a beaucoup d'expérience
dans différents domaines
ce maire de grey est reconnue et non pas
isolé et part qu'il est important
aujourd'hui d'avoir des soutiens aussi
important que celui de notre présidente
de région de notre président département
de nos présidents d'agglomérations car
les projets ne pourront pas les réaliser
tout seul donc c'est pour ça que je
pense que notre équipe et pour laquelle
je suis en tête dimanche prochain a
beaucoup de lacunes pour conduire notre
ville dans les prochaines années mercy
le débat touche à sa fin dernier coup
d'oeil sur les chronos nicolas une neuf
minutes 53 anne klein frémont vous êtes
à 9 minutes 32 et enfin philippe guillen
neuf minutes 34 merci à tous les trois
d'avoir participé le débat est à
retrouver en replay sur tv 78 et en
podcast chez nos confrères de radio
sensations yvin le second tour des
élections municipales pour rappel se
tient le dimanche 28 juin
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]